[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
TY WARD: How're you doing, man?
KANWER SINGH: Fine, thank you.
TY WARD: And before
we get started,
I do have to say, now,
very impressive stuff here,
but I just want to let
you guys know this guy is
very important, big deal.
I found this picture.
Now I don't know if you guys
know who's in this photo.
Show of hands, who knows who's
in this photo, besides Humble?
You, right there, who's that?
AUDIENCE: Nick Jonas.
TY WARD: That's
Nick Jonas, right?
And the funniest and best
part about this photo
was when I first saw
it, I didn't even
notice Nick and Priyanka Chopra.
So not only is this
guy big enough deal
to be invited to that wedding,
steal a swagged out photo
with the two of them, but he
also literally stole the photo.
That speaks volumes
to his energy.
All right.
KANWER SINGH: That's
actually the official wedding
photo for us.
That's the one where
everyone was taking a picture
with the bride and groom.
TY WARD: Is that right?
KANWER SINGH: We were just like
we're going to b-boy stance it.
TY WARD: Dude, I love it.
With the blue suit?
That's like so swag.
KANWER SINGH: Mint
chocolate chip,
that's what I called myself.
TY WARD: I love it.
All right, so we're
going to real talk today.
I got some cards here
with some questions,
but we can take a seat.
We're going to get into it,
trying to be in-- candid.
We're going to talk
about the book.
We're going to talk a
little bit about your life,
your background, which kind of
leads me to my first question.
So you wrote a book
called "Unlearn."
KANWER SINGH: Yes.
TY WARD: And you're
talking to folks right now
at Google who've
literally staked
their entire career on
everything that they've
learned.
So tell me what's
"Unlearn" mean?
What are we supposed
to be unlearning,
and how does that aid
itself in happiness?
KANWER SINGH: I think a lot of
the times, the most important
idea is that we need to
understand to better our lives,
we've already had.
We've always had them.
Oftentimes, we've had them
as kids, and then life comes,
and it piles us up
with a lot of bullshit.
And then all of a sudden, we
think that we're somebody else,
so we need to be
something different.
And when I was working as
a school schoolteacher--
and this is a story I
tell in the book-- is
if you tell a child,
hey, put on your boots
and then put on your snow pants,
the kid puts on his boots first
and then tries to put his
snow pants over the boots.
And you're like, oh, I get it.
They took it exactly literal.
And you realize how
much of an empty vessel
these kids really are.
And we were once these same
empty vessels, and then slowly,
but surely, all the stuff
that society teaches us,
our parents teach us, family
teaches us, media teaches us,
it crystallizes in who we are.
And then we start
to think that this
was tattooed into
our soul, and this
is who we are the whole time.
And the reality is it's
not, and we can go back
to a better essence
of who we were
by not acquiring more
things, but instead, letting
go of a lot of stuff.
And that's kind of
where "Unlearn" was.
So when I was in my most
challenging time in life,
I was searching for
that Tumblr quote
or that idea that
was going to save me
from all of my troubles.
And then I realized I wasn't
going to learn anything new.
I had to let go of
my expectations,
the idealistic view I had
of the world, my mentality
to blame everybody
else except for myself
for my problems and
my circumstances.
And when I began letting
go of these things,
I started feeling lighter.
And as I felt lighter, I
was able to take a bigger
journey inside myself,
learn who I was,
because they always
said be yourself,
but you can't be yourself
if you don't know yourself.
So as I got to
know myself better,
I was able to live a more
authentic life, which
often, people refer to as
their best life, right?
So from that
perspective, I think
it's important to kind of
let go more than we gain.
And I mean, society,
consumerism, everything,
it teaches us you
have to acquire more.
You need more, and more, and
more, and more to be better.
But I think the reality
is, we really need
to be polishing things off.
We need to grab
some big sandpaper
and get rid of all this
rust because a lot of this
is formed over the years.
And we don't even realize it.
TY WARD: Totally.
You just talked a
little bit about--
I mean, we're already
off script, by the way.
This is--
KANWER SINGH: Fantastic.
TY WARD: I'll
leave it over here.
You just talked a little bit
about kind of knowing yourself.
And you're also wearing
a shirt that says create,
rather than find yourself.
KANWER SINGH: Yes,
also designed by me.
TY WARD: I had a feeling that
was definitely not a plug,
KANWER SINGH: Not yet.
We'll plug it later.
TY WARD: So with that in
mind, though, who are you?
I mean, I read it off
the cart, but like
who are you that gave you--
I always like to think
that our lives are
the perfect curriculum for
everything that we'll need.
But who are you, and
where have you been?
And what have you
learned and seen
that kind of made you feel
like you could write this book,
and it would
resonate with people?
KANWER SINGH: I
don't think who I am
is what is important
to me writing the book.
I think me writing the book
is the important part to me
writing the book.
You meet a lot of people
who talk about, oh, I
want to write a book one day.
And you're like, you
just have to write it.
There's no qualifications,
or degrees,
or template that
you have to follow.
You just literally have
to put pen to paper,
and just start smashing
on the keyboard,
and let those ideas come out.
And I think for
me, what I realized
is the things that
kind of tickle my fancy
and get me excited are
stimulation and learning.
I'm a lifelong learner.
That doesn't necessarily
mean I was a great student.
mean I'm sitting and reading
books all day.
Sometimes I'm reading the
headlines, and that's it.
And sometimes it's just
watching YouTube videos.
But I enjoy learning new things.
I enjoy having my
biases challenged.
I enjoy being
like, oh, I thought
this was how it was
going to be, or this
is how it's supposed to be,
and then have somebody just
totally flip me on my head.
And it doesn't attack
my ego or my identity
if my beliefs are challenged.
That actually gets me excited.
It lets me know that
I'm not growing stale.
I'm still able to grow.
Because if you're not growing,
then you're not really alive.
So for me, is that
that's who I am
and the excitement of
having the spark in my brain
and being like, oh my god.
One day, this is
going to be tangible.
I want to make it happen.
As I was saying, that music
video that we just like--
and that's because
Lily Singh is just
a monster in the way she
works and productivity.
We wrote that song.
We recorded that song
and edited the song.
And then we shot the
video, edited the video,
everything in 72 hours.
And having an idea of hey,
this would be really cool
if we can be on the
Toronto Raptors court.
Well, how do we do it?
I don't know.
Let's call everybody.
And it was actually Google
that made it happen.
TY WARD: All right.
KANWER SINGH: Yeah, it
wasn't anybody else.
Google-- they pulled
the right lever,
and they got us
into the stadium.
But it's just having these ideas
and realizing that impossible
literally means nothing.
And we can make anything happen.
And that, for me,
is so exciting.
And the further I go on
this journey, the more pages
of my book of excuses I have
to keep ripping out and feeling
like, oh, I can't do that.
Oh, guys like me aren't
supposed to do that.
People that look like me
aren't supposed to be here.
And then just slowly
like, no, you continually
pave your own path, and
just, magical things happen.
And normally, it's just
about leaving the house,
talking to new people, and
using your fear as a compass,
rather than viewing your
fear as a roadblock.
TY WARD: That's awesome, and
that makes a lot of total sense
behind the whole ethos
of create yourself.
KANWER SINGH: Yeah.
TY WARD: So I like that you
talked about the music video
that we were just watching
because you're quite the emcee.
And I know that that's--
KANWER SINGH: Yeah, I get busy.
TY WARD: Yo, yeah.
Yeah, you get busy.
You get down.
KANWER SINGH: I am not
humble about my rap skills.
TY WARD: I think that's more
like a funny play on words
with that pun.
KANWER SINGH: It is.
Humble is also a verb.
People forget that.
TY WARD: Oh.
Wait, OK, so let's
talk about that.
How did you get to
the name Humble?
KANWER SINGH: The name was
purely born out of spite.
I was--
TY WARD: I knew it.
I knew it.
KANWER SINGH: In Sikh
heritage and Sikh philosophy,
the number one challenge
to your peace is your ego.
And so when I was
on hip hop forums
and just participating on my
favorite outcast chat boards,
my username was just
the word Humble.
And then I got involved
in online rap battles,
and then in a rap battle,
I had a line that said,
rappers are basic,
emcees are more advanced.
But I'm even better,
I'm the poet.
And it was just a cocky
line to kind of say
that I'm better than
these rappers and emcees.
I ended up winning this
really big tournament
where I had to compete with
five, six different guys.
And to rub it in, I changed
my name to Humble the Poet.
TY WARD: Oh.
You mean a time for the actual--
did you win, and
then you changed it?
KANWER SINGH: No, I
won, then changed it.
TY WARD: OK.
KANWER SINGH: To
rub it in, yeah.
So everybody knew.
And years later, I'm
in a friend's basement.
And we have a microphone
against the mattress.
And I recorded my
first verse, and it
was eight guys in the
room because that's
what you do when you rap, just
fill the room full of guys.
And they're like, well, do
you have a rap name yet?
And I was like, I was
thinking Humble the Poet.
And they were like,
that's a stupid name.
And then one guy's like,
that name's too long.
You need a short name.
You need a one syllable name.
I'm like, you know what?
Screw all you guys.
I'm going to stick
with Humble the Poet
because you guys don't
think it will work.
I'm going to make it work.
And they were right
in some instances.
This was right before
social media tags and names.
A shorter name would have
probably been better,
but now, I'm stuck with it.
I'm stubborn.
And it's not going anywhere.
TY WARD: I like that.
Have you been stubborn
your whole life?
KANWER SINGH: Yes.
TY WARD: Yeah?
KANWER SINGH: Very.
TY WARD: So this
is not something
that just came with your rise.
It's like, you always had
that spirit of, I got this.
KANWER SINGH: I've been
stubborn and defiant.
And yeah, just recently,
I connected with a cousin.
He lives in New Zealand.
And our schedules
matched up in Germany,
and I met him for the
first time since like '93.
And he said to me, my
first memory of you
was you were like
five years old,
and you just kept
looking at me saying, no.
And I wasn't even asking
you to do anything.
You just kept looking
at me defiantly,
like if you do ask me to do
something, the answer is no.
And I kind of realized that
that kind of clicked something
in the patterns in my life,
where I definitely am not
a fan of being told what to do.
I definitely enjoy the idea
of trying to mold things
my way, versus trying to fit in.
And there were a
lot of challenging
years where I definitely didn't
fit in, and it almost broke me.
And I wanted to just give
up and kind of blend in
with everybody else.
But then eventually, you
realize that, as Dr. Seuss says,
why try to fit in when you
were born to stand out?
TY WARD: It's funny
that you say that.
So we have a building
here on campus, Bin 7--
oh, nope, I made that up--
Bin 4 that literally has that--
KANWER SINGH: Oh, for real?
TY WARD: Printed on the wall,
coincidentally on the way
to the bathroom.
KANWER SINGH: Nice.
TY WARD: I'm not really sure
what the idea behind that was,
but I just noticed
it for the first time
yesterday, because
I love that quote.
KANWER SINGH: That's dope.
TY WARD: OK, so you
mentioned that you grew up
with Sikh religious background.
My curiosity there is so we
have a audacious Humble, young
Humble, Sikh
religious background.
How did the two of those
influences meet together?
And how have they
shaped you, like how
you lived your life and
ultimately, written this book?
KANWER SINGH: I mean,
definitely, Sikhi
can be viewed as a religion.
I think more importantly,
it's more of a philosophy,
and it more kind of
falls under the umbrella
of eastern philosophy, when
you think about Buddhism,
Hinduism-- just the
idea of cyclical life.
Out here, a lot of
the philosophies,
whether it's Christianity,
Judaism, Islam,
are straight lines, through
the beginning, middle, and end.
Do all these things,
and then there's
something, a reward or a
consequence at the end of it.
Whereas on the eastern side,
everything's in a cycle.
Birth and death, the seasons,
everything go that way.
So I think under those
two umbrellas, they
only kind of look at
the world being shaped
by those main philosophies.
My parents force fed Sikhi
as a dogmatic religion
to me as a kid the
same way parents force
their kids to play the piano.
And you hate every moment
of it, but then you grow up,
and you're like, oh, now
I have a really full tool
belt of things that are
really going to benefit me.
And I mean, the idea that
turmeric is so popular now
and everybody eats it.
And that was the stuff the
kids would make fun of me
for having stains on my clothes.
And they'd call it
curry back then.
And it's kind of like seeing
how things have changed so much.
So I think what it
ended up being was,
my mom kind of sold the idea to
me, telling me these stories.
Because there's a lot of civil
disobedience in Sikh heritage.
Punjabi Sikh specifically
in India right now only
represent 2% of the population.
So I'm a minority there.
I'm a minority here.
I'm a minority everywhere I go.
So ideas of safe spaces
don't exist for me,
don't exist for my people.
We've never had them.
If we do have them,
we'll probably
feel very uncomfortable
because that's not
something we're used to.
Kind of having a history
of thriving in chaos,
having a history of not being
planted on one piece of land
has definitely encouraged me to
continue my nomadic lifestyle
as well.
The philosophy in itself--
Sikh means student.
So to see me already being
a student of life, me
getting an education, being
an elementary school teacher--
all school schoolteachers
have signed up
to be lifelong learners as well.
And I think it's
that natural need
to try to learn as
much as you can.
And again, the way my
parents have taught it to me
was about being students
of God, worshipping God.
And the thing is, all the
texts are written in poetry.
So you can easily
take the word God
and replace it with the truth.
So you can be
students of the truth.
And now, instead of
looking at the will of God,
you can be looking
at the will of truth.
And that can be everything from
respecting what gravity is,
respecting human
nature, understanding
how the world works and
becoming students of that.
And with that, it's an endless
journey of learning the truth.
So what my truth is
today on this level
won't be my truth in five years.
So now you become
this lifelong learner,
understanding universal
truths and personal truths
and trying to have them come
to terms with each other.
And that's a never
ending journey for me.
So for me in the
beginning, there
was a lot of rejection
for it because there are
a lot of cultural influences.
So when I first started
rapping, people were like,
oh, this guy thinks he's black.
Why is he rapping?
And I'm sitting there
like, every hymn I was ever
taught to memorize rhymed.
Over half of the gurus that
I was taught to learn from
ran armies and had
bodies under their belt.
And I was listening to
gangster rap before NWA.
My gurus rhymed and killed.
This was something I
was always exposed to.
If you go to temples
in Toronto, they
have pictures, photographs
of dead bodies hanging
on the walls of young men
who fought for a cause
and gave up their lives.
We were exposed to this.
We were a very martial people.
We've always been encouraged
to be [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
means always be ready,
always be prepared.
Some people believe in
a ceremonial dagger.
But the reality of that is
we've been fighting wars,
and we've been doing
that because we've
been a minority our
entire existence.
So seeing the connections,
and as I got older,
being able to own it
myself and being like,
all right, here are the
elements that really
connect with me authentically.
And it is to be not only a
student, but to be a soldier,
and then learning
that hey, the soldier
isn't that guy who's just
simply outside on a Saturday
afternoon, protesting
for Palestine.
The soldier is the one
fighting the biggest
battles on the inside.
And those are the
ones that I really
had to take a lot of times to
deal with, especially when I
decided I was going to--
talking about the issues
that were happening
in Sri Lanka when the
Tamil Tigers were fighting
for their freedom, or the
ongoing conflict in Israel
and Palestine, or any human
rights issue that exists,
you write about them,
and you explore them.
But then you take it deeper,
and you're like, wait,
it's not about these
political issues.
It's about power, oppression,
greed, human nature,
and then our best source for
all of that is ourselves.
And then I started talking
about my oppression
when I oppress, when I'm
chasing power, when I'm greedy.
And that really
changed the trajectory
of my art and my work,
and that brought me
closer back to Sikh
heritage, which
was always talking about that.
If you read any of the
writings in the hymns in Sikh
scriptures, there's no talk
about growing your beard
or wearing a turban.
This is a lot more
heritage and cultural.
This just talks about your
lust, your greed, your anger,
your attachment, your ego,
how these things impact
our happiness.
And there's no talk
about, this is a sin.
This is right, this is wrong.
There's just
writings from people
who are trying
their best to have
a healthy relationship with
what they consider the truth.
And you're sharing
it poetically,
and I think for our people
being in North India,
North India has been the
front door for invaders
since Alexander the Great.
And for any group of
people to have art,
you need some stability.
We didn't have the
stability out there.
So the moment our families
started coming and crossing
the pond over North America
in the '60s and the '70s,
we're that generation who had
that stability to explore.
So that's why you're
seeing an explosion of it.
That's why you have Rupi Kaur.
That's why you have Lily Singh.
That's why you have [INAUDIBLE].
That's why you have me.
You're having this
first crop of artists,
but now, that's the
beginning of the wave.
Because when people
ask me, who's
the artistic person in
your family, I don't know.
I don't know if it's
my mom or my dad.
They were never
given the opportunity
to explore creativity.
My father has a master's
degree, and he didn't have
an opportunity to explore that.
He came to Canada
and drove a cab.
And so for us, it's trying to
pick up where they left off
because we never had-- and
even in our history as people,
we don't have a
lineage of poets.
We have maybe two or three.
We don't have a lineage
of artists and painters.
There's a lot of hiccups in our
history because of invasions
and most recently,
when the British came.
And they changed a lot of stuff.
So for me now, it's about
finding myself, but also trying
to continue this heritage.
And the challenges are not so
much people on the outside,
but also people on the inside.
Because fundamentalism is people
who find comfort in the past.
And people are
like, hey, this is
what a guy with a beard and
turban is supposed to do.
You're not looking like that.
You're not acting like that.
You're making us uncomfortable.
So I get a lot of
resistance internally
within the community.
And instead of having a chip
on my shoulder and being like,
my people and my
culture don't accept me,
I have to recognize that hey,
they're speaking their fear.
Because now I'm in a
position of influence.
And they want me to
adhere to culture
because they're afraid
that I can rewrite culture.
And that's the challenge.
But it's my job to
continue the story
and write culture and
understand that hey,
my parents had this many tools.
I have the education
and the life
experiences with
this many tools.
What can I do to ensure
that the next generation has
this many tools?
So, it's been an
interesting journey,
but I think me, and
specifically Lily, just--
because I stay
with her out here,
and we spend a lot
of time together--
we talk about this a lot as
to recognizing our influence.
People are copying my tattoos.
People tie their turban
the way I tie it.
And you're like, OK, well,
there's a responsibility here
now.
And then also just with
the newer generation,
folks don't care.
They don't label
as much anymore.
Generation Z, they
don't care what you are.
And what influence
are we having on them?
And how can we have
a positive influence?
So for me, it's like the
overarching theme I'm always
encouraging and trying to
shove down everybody's throat
is not look like me, act
like me, dress like me.
It's chase
self-awareness like me.
And if you want to
be like me, that
means being the best version
of you, whatever that is.
And if that's a purple
mohawk, and a tutu,
and roller skates
to work, then do it.
That's what I'm
encouraging everybody
to kind of do within
their own, and be
your own student of truth.
And you don't have
to look a certain way
to make that happen.
TY WARD: Couldn't
have said it better.
That's [INAUDIBLE] why
you wrote the book.
My next question is going
to be about happiness.
Because I think happiness--
a lot of times, we think
about happiness as a feeling.
But you talk a lot about
happiness being a mindset.
And I really want to get
into what that means.
More specifically, how
do you define that?
How is happiness a mindset?
And then, what have you
done, and what can others
do to sort of cultivate
this mindset of happiness?
KANWER SINGH: One
step before that,
I do not believe it's
important or even possible
to be happy all the time.
I actually think that would
be detrimental to our lives.
We rarely learn anything
when we're happy.
TY WARD: That's very true.
KANWER SINGH: Because
Bill Gates said
success is a lousy teacher.
We learn when the
shit hits the fan.
And unhappiness is simply
when the picture in our head
doesn't match the
picture in front of us.
And now, I may not be able to
control the picture in front
of me, but I have
much more control
in the picture in my head.
So managing my expectations
and having that power
allows me to decide how
happy I am a lot more often.
In no way, shape,
or form am I saying
people who have dealt with
severe trauma can just,
now I'm happy.
I'm not encouraging that at all.
But I am encouraging taking
a lot more responsibility.
Because when we
take responsibility,
it's not necessarily
taking the blame.
It's empowering ourselves.
If I blame you for
all my circumstances,
then you have all the
power in my circumstances.
If I take some
personal responsibility
for my circumstances, even
the 1% of whatever it is,
now I have 1% more power.
So for me, happiness
is a mindset
because the recipe for
happiness is very simple.
It's gratitude,
it's appreciation.
If I bought you a
Lamborghini, you're
happy because you
appreciate Lamborghinis.
Maybe if I bought you a puppy,
you wouldn't appreciate it
because you're like, this guy
just gave me a bunch of work.
TY WARD: What about a
puppy and a Lamborghini?
KANWER SINGH: A puppy that
can drive a Lamborghini.
TY WARD: Oh, you just
took it to the next level.
KANWER SINGH: Yeah,
a puppy chauffeur.
TY WARD: Oh!
That would be amazing.
What would you call him?
KANWER SINGH: Speedy?
TY WARD: Speedy?
OK.
I like that.
I'd call him Ronald.
KANWER SINGH: Ronald?
TY WARD: Yeah.
KANWER SINGH: That works, too.
TY WARD: Yeah, yeah.
I didn't mean to cut you off.
KANWER SINGH: No, not at all.
TY WARD: I love side tangents
because I feel like that's--
KANWER SINGH: Ronald
the puppy that
drives the Lambo that always
finds parking, the best spots.
TY WARD: Always finds parking.
And if he doesn't, he just loops
the block a couple of times.
KANWER SINGH: Yeah, and he
just says, yo, let me just
drop you off at the front.
You handle yours, I'll
worry about parking.
TY WARD: And you're like, dude.
Yeah, I love that.
KANWER SINGH: He would be
the most popular guy in LA.
TY WARD: He seriously would.
We should actually start
a little Instagram for him
already because I feel like--
KANWER SINGH: He would
probably be too cool for this.
He would probably
be at Coachella.
TY WARD: Oh, he would be.
He'd be on his
way out to Coach--
actually, no, you're right.
If he was on his way,
he's already there.
He's probably already there.
KANWER SINGH: He's
already there, yeah.
TY WARD: So speak--
I like the way this is going.
Because there's a lot of--
what you guys don't know--
I mean, you probably
can tell none of this
is what was planned.
But we're kind of just
freestyling right now.
And I want to talk a lot more--
KANWER SINGH: You're going
to hear from my publicist.
TY WARD: Oh, I know,
I know, I know.
KANWER SINGH: She's like, we
made all these very interesting
boring questions, and you
didn't ask any of them.
TY WARD: Well, we did.
We've interwoven some of them.
KANWER SINGH: OK.
OK.
TY WARD: We've
interwoven some of them.
But I want to talk
about hip hop right now.
One of my favorite topics--
I know it's probably one
of your favorite topics.
And I think that hip hop has had
a pretty big influence on you
and your writing style.
And I really want to talk about
your hip hop past and present
and how it has influenced the
way that you wrote this book.
Because for you
that don't know yet
and who don't have a copy of
the book yet, which I'm sure
you all will preorder-- you
can preorder it on Amazon.
KANWER SINGH: So
it's actually-- oh,
I think my publicist
gave you the wrong note.
It came out April 9.
TY WARD: It came out April 9--
KANWER SINGH: So we're out.
TY WARD: So it's
already out on Amazon.
There are some free copies
for those of you brave enough
to adventure into the front row.
KANWER SINGH: Oh,
yeah, there's literally
free copies on the chairs.
TY WARD: Yeah.
KANWER SINGH: Clever.
TY WARD: For those of
you that don't know,
the book is written in a very--
I would say unique way, where
it's using lots of quotes
and then expounding
upon said quotes.
So I want to understand hip hop.
How has it influenced you
in how you wrote this book?
KANWER SINGH: So I've
got two older sisters.
So when I grew up, whatever
music I listened to
was whatever they listened to.
So I'm listening to New Kids on
the Block and George Michael.
And Vanilla Ice was
probably the first raps--
"Ice Ice Baby" was
one of the first rap
songs I had memorized because
these are the top 40 pop
tracks that my sisters,
when they were young girls,
they were listening to.
The thing with hip
hop specifically--
and it might be for
other genres of music,
I just personally never
had that experience--
is there's always going
to be that one song that
hits you with such tenacious
reality that it just hits you.
And you have an
involuntary reaction to it.
And for me, it was actually
in high school with Outkast.
André 3000-- "I came into
this world high as a bird from
second hand cocaine powder.
I know it sounds absurd."
And just hearing those lines
and then seeing this cool rapper
wearing a turban in his music
videos with five half-naked
ladies making everything look
like this super futuristic--
both futuristic and nostalgic
African royalty vibe.
And you're just like, I've
never seen this imagery before.
And it just hits you to this
level where you're just like,
I want more.
And you just go
into this deep dive.
And for me, I think it
was, I got really exposed
to a lot more of the
heavier, deeper hip hop.
So I'm talking about like,
Lauryn Hill, Outkast,
Goodie Mob, Common,
Wyclef's First Project,
all the Ruckus Movement-- so
Black Star, Mos Def, Talib
Kweli.
All of this stuff really
resonated with me.
It felt like modern
day Bob Marley.
It felt like this universal
stuff that hit me.
And I already enjoy
putting words together.
I've been writing short stories
and poems and everything
since I was seven, eight years
old and loved sharing it.
And to see these guys do
it on such an elite level,
it really impacted me.
And it was probably
the first foundation
of my authentic self-confidence.
It was connecting
with these people,
and they were telling
stories that mattered.
And hearing rappers-- when
you're in high school,
and you look like
Master Splinter
because you have like
three strands of a beard.
And all your friends
are starting to date,
but you don't have the
confidence to ask any girl out,
and plus, you don't
feel attractive.
And even the men that have
these beautiful turbans
and full beards, you don't
look like them either.
You're in your
transition period.
You're going from
your duckling to swan.
And but at the same
time, it impacts you.
And a lot of young guys,
they cut their hair.
They want to fit in.
They want to blend in.
And I think for
me, hip hop helped
me see the value in who I was.
And hearing rappers say--
like Pusha T, the
power's in my hair.
And just hearing certain
things, it emboldened me a lot.
And I realized it was
not only-- it saved
my life in so many occasions.
And then as I got older, I
felt I needed to contribute.
I owed it to hip hop
to contribute and write
that next song for that
next kid in high school.
Whatever they're dealing
with, whether they're
dealing with their
weight, whether they're
dealing with the
fact that they don't
have two parents, whether
they're dealing with the fact
that they're in
love with somebody
that they're not allowed to
be in love with-- anything.
I wanted to tell their
stories because I realized
that's what hip hop did for me.
It told my story when I
couldn't tell it myself,
but it gave me the
strength to write my story.
And as human beings, that's
all we've been doing.
We've been carving stuff on
caves for the next generation.
And we've been telling stories
and passing stories down.
And not only that,
record our history
that also helps us
pave for our future.
And for me, that's why hip
hop, to me, is so important.
And also, from a
literary art perspective,
it's the most
challenging, technical--
it's the best form
of literary art.
Jay-Z is significantly
much more talented
than Shakespeare in my opinion.
And you take a popular rock
song, and you print it out.
It's like this many words.
You take any rapper's
verse, it's this much.
And when you think of your
Jay-Z's and your Lil Wayne's,
these guys don't even
put pen to paper.
They're building all
of this in their heads,
and then going straight
to the microphone.
And they didn't do it
for the novelty of it.
They did it out of necessity in
their life because some of them
didn't have the tools
to write anything down.
And so for me,
it's the evolution
of literary art
to a point that I
don't think many people
are appreciating it.
And that's why I do
appreciate having
Humble the Poet as my name
to try to elevate the art
form in itself.
TY WARD: Totally, totally.
So I mean, with
your blessing, I'd
love to actually just like--
this book, by the way--
I am a slow reader.
And I mean that.
If I had to read
it front to back--
this is real talk here-- it'd
probably take me about a month
to get through it.
I'm being vulnerable right now.
But this book is really
cool because it's
almost like a magic 8 ball
on steroids that also just
knows you personally.
You flip it open to any
spot and find a gem.
KANWER SINGH: I'm
not a reader either.
I mean, I have a full bookshelf
now, because every time you
have a meeting with a
publisher, they send you home
with a bag of books, or they'll
mail you a box of books.
So I got all the cool books.
But this book was--
I taught the third grade.
So I thought to myself,
what would an eight--
if you can explain it
to an eight-year-old,
you can explain it to anybody.
And so I made a book
for people who say
they don't like reading books.
Because the teacher in me
knows everybody loves reading.
They just haven't
found that right book.
And the big thing I used to
tell my students' parents
were like, hey, if they want
to read the back of the cereal
box, let them.
Our goal is to get them to
love reading, not love reading
something specific.
We'll find the
academic stuff later.
Right now, we just need
them to find that one book.
Because once they
find that one book,
they'll be hooked on reading.
And for me, my goal
was to make that book
for people who don't read.
And it's been a
challenge, especially
working with
publishers because they
want to hit that target market.
And I was like, I want to hit
that market that doesn't know
they need this book,
not just the market who
has read every other book that
might be in the same vein.
TY WARD: That's totally--
KANWER SINGH: But you can
definitely open this book up
to any page, and we'll
do it live right now.
And I feel like you'll find
something you connect with.
TY WARD: All right, so I
want the audience right now
to give me-- don't say anything.
KANWER SINGH: You guys can try
yourself if you have a book.
And there's some
in the front row
if anybody's bold
enough to move up.
TY WARD: Pop one
open if you want.
And right now, just hold
an intention, right?
What are you feeling right now?
KANWER SINGH: Are you guys
going to make it mystical?
TY WARD: Oh, we're going
to make it mystical.
Are you kidding me?
I can't be sitting up here
with Humble the Poet--
KANWER SINGH: They
already think I'm
mystical because
I've got a beard,
and now you're going
to make it even worse.
TY WARD: Let's
complete the facade.
I love it.
KANWER SINGH: All right,
let's complete the facade.
TY WARD: It's about
making a vibe.
KANWER SINGH: You're all going
to turn into the modern day
Osho.
TY WARD: All right.
If the shoe fits, you know?
All right.
Here we go.
"The strongest don't survive.
The most adaptable do."
KANWER SINGH: Facts.
TY WARD: Facts.
Let's talk about that.
What does that mean?
KANWER SINGH: I think it's
just a challenge on some
of the cliched things you hear.
It's like only the
strongest survive.
Me leaving the
safety and security
of being an elementary school
teacher, a government job that
happened in Canada, where all
my colleagues were my friends,
and the priority were
the kids, and nobody
was in competition with me.
Everybody was getting paid
whatever they got paid,
and your pay grade
went by raises.
And then I left that to go into
the world of entertainment,
which is the jungle
in comparison.
And the first people
that recognized my talent
weren't looking to help me.
They were looking to rip me
to shreds or profit off of me.
And what I realized
was it wasn't
my strength that was going
to help me move forward.
It was going to be my ability to
adapt, learn, and move forward.
And especially as a
stubborn individual,
that was a big lesson I had
to tell myself that is, hey,
you have to adjust yourselves.
You can't control the wind.
You have to adjust yourselves.
And for me, that's kind of
where this idea came from.
And I mean, I'm sure
Darwin would agree.
It's the adaptable
ones that kick it.
And I think very
often, translating that
into our modern
society, it would
be it's not the most
talented people that
are going to succeed.
It's the people with
the grit, the people
with the perseverance,
and the people
who are willing not to adjust
their goals, but people who
are willing to address
their strategies
and their routes to get there.
TY WARD: Well said, well said.
Now, I want to be
respectful of time
because I definitely get a
sense everyone's really paying
attention and super focused.
You don't understand.
This is not generally a
laptops down community,
so we try to
multi-task everything.
KANWER SINGH: Oh, really?
OK.
TY WARD: And I don't
know if you've noticed.
I don't even see one out.
Everybody's just eyes
forward right now.
So I sense--
KANWER SINGH: Oh.
We've got one with the laptop.
He was like, oh,
crap, let me close it.
TY WARD: Oh, oh, no.
OK, so he's probably doing
something superficial
that's related to--
KANWER SINGH: Hey,
you know what?
Listen, I'm one of the
people who is lucky enough
to get invites to Zeitgeist,
and even once in a while,
I got to pull out my laptop.
TY WARD: Every once in a while.
KANWER SINGH: Sometimes--
TY WARD: Got to
scratch that itch.
KANWER SINGH: Ah, I got
to check that email.
I get it.
Life happens in
real time, I get it.
TY WARD: So I mean, if you're
cool with it, I'd love to--
I feel like keeping it mystic.
I'm getting a sense that there
are some questions out there
in the audience for you.
KANWER SINGH: I'm just saying,
you're making it mystic.
I don't want anyone to think
that I consider myself mystic.
TY WARD: I just like
mystical things.
But are you cool with--
KANWER SINGH: Yeah--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KANWER SINGH: 100%.
TY WARD: All righty.
This is a cool moment.
KANWER SINGH: What is that?
TY WARD: Question back
there, check this out.
Almost over threw, I apologize.
AUDIENCE: Hi, can you hear me?
KANWER SINGH: Oh my god,
that's a microphone.
TY WARD: Yes.
KANWER SINGH: That is fly.
AUDIENCE: Brown squares.
So, thank you for coming.
KANWER SINGH: Thank
you for having me.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's coincidence
or it's meant to be
that I would just
finish watching Nipsey
Hussle's funeral service,
and then coming into this.
Because that was speaking
the truth, and so is this.
On that note, who is your
top modern favorite rappers?
KANWER SINGH: Artistically,
probably André 3000.
Just everything he does
has just been fantastic.
I think talking about
Nipsey Hussle in terms
of people who dropped the
most gems and the jewels,
it'll probably be.
In their work, probably
Jay-Z drops the most wisdom.
He's not really known for it.
But if you take a listen,
especially his 4:44 album,
that's like a manual
on how to be an adult.
It's such a fantastic album.
AUDIENCE: That's actually
my angel number, is 444.
KANWER SINGH: 444?
OK, yeah, so that
one's really good.
I got two chapters in
here dedicated to lessons
I learned from 50 Cent.
TY WARD: That's awesome.
KANWER SINGH: So
they're there as well.
So 50 for me is a big one.
And actually, Nipsey
Hussle, it was
a-- and that's a
little heartbreaking
situation, but probably a
week before it all happened,
we had just
connected on Twitter.
And my goal-- and I
landed here in LA.
I got the news--
I was flying back from India.
So my flight was from Mumbai to
Frankfurt and Frankfurt to LA.
And then landing in
Frankfurt, I found out.
I got the news.
And yeah, one of my goals
was like, all right,
you going to let go of your
Canadian sensibilities.
And you're going
to find this guy.
You're going to keep poking
at him until he meets you.
You're not going to
take no for an answer.
And that was on my to do
list, this trip to LA.
And it was a very
heartbreaking situation.
But I do-- for those--
a lot of people have heard
the news of Nipsey Hussle.
I do really encourage you guys
to check out his interviews.
He is one of the most-- and
that's how we connected.
Because I said he's one of
the most important minds
and has one of the
most important stories
of our generation.
And I think he appreciated
that, and we connected that way.
But his story-- his
credits have rolled.
And all we can do is
continue his legacy.
But beyond that, yeah, 50
Cent, André 3000 as an artist.
I'm loving what
Gambino does right now.
I got to meet him years
ago, and he reminded me
that the only reason I should be
doing this is because it's fun.
He chases the fun, and
when you look at his work,
you realize he's
literally chasing the fun.
So I'm really trying to
follow in his footsteps
and do the same.
TY WARD: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TY WARD: Great question.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, OK, all right.
KANWER SINGH: So how often do
people get hit in the head?
TY WARD: So it's soft.
It's plush.
In there somewhere
is a tiny microphone.
KANWER SINGH: Oh, it's
a tiny microphone?
Not like one of these.
TY WARD: No, no, no.
Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: You wouldn't want to
get hit in the head with it.
TY WARD: No, you
wouldn't want to.
But you might.
AUDIENCE: It hurts, but it's--
TY WARD: He made it.
Look.
AUDIENCE: Well,
yeah, I mean, I did.
I'm expecting it.
TY WARD: OK.
You're absolutely right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thanks
so much for coming today.
I know you're talking about a
new slate or roster of artists,
particularly Indian
artists kind of rising now.
Where do you view--
I mean, have you
seen "Gully Boy" yet?
KANWER SINGH: Yeah, I
haven't seen the film,
but I've seen the track.
AUDIENCE: OK, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I was just curious
if you had exposure
to the growing, yet nascent
hip hop scene in India,
and where do you
think that's going.
KANWER SINGH: It's fantastic.
It's fantastic on
so many levels.
So coincidentally,
when I was in Mumbai,
we ran into Ranveer, who stars
in that movie, at a party.
And I have it on my Instagram.
He rapped "Still D.R.E."
end to end.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
KANWER SINGH: And then
later on in the party,
he rapped "Hypnotize"
end to end.
He knew all the words.
The thing is with hip hop, hip
hop is like soccer for music.
It's the most universal,
accessible musical art
because you don't have to pay
for expensive guitar lessons.
You don't have to
pay for equipment.
All you need for hip hop
is a story and a beat.
And we all kind of come with
a heartbeat out the box.
It's also the tool of
the underrepresented
to tell their stories.
So in terms of
hip hop right now,
it started 1520 Sedgwick
Avenue in the Bronx,
and it expanded
slowly, but surely.
And outside of English
speakers, the next language
that has had a couple of decades
under the belt is French.
So French hip hop has
evolved magnificently.
The thing is, all the necessary
ingredients for hip hop
to exist have always
been in India.
All the major
languages in India--
Hindi, Punjabi, Gujarati,
Urdu, Madrassi--
all these languages,
they're already poetic.
They're already made to rhyme.
As I said, all the hymns that
my mother taught me growing up,
they all rhyme.
All the hymns are
written in poetry.
You could rap them.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the Mahabharata
is like the longest poem ever.
KANWER SINGH: Exactly.
They're already poetry.
So now this is just adding
poetry to your heartbeat.
So from that perspective, it's
kind of always been there.
It's kind of like when the
NBA realized, hey, if we go
to Africa, everyone's so tall.
We can start grooming these
players to join the league.
I feel like that's
India's time right now.
They're grooming the players
because you can't even
compare a hood in the
US to a slum in India.
It's a completely
different level
of what they're going through.
And their stories
are so important,
and their emotions are so raw.
And the art is so
prevalent there.
And India is also the
mother of percussion.
India and Africa is where
percussion came from.
So from that perspective,
it's such a natural fit,
and it's so exciting.
Where it is right
now, it's amazing.
So Raftaar, who's one of
the most prominent rappers
out there right now, he's
a good friend of mine.
But at the same time, it's
cool because on his hand,
he has a game tattoo.
He was inspired by the game.
And he's probably a bigger
artist globally now.
And so for me, it's
been exciting to be
able to connect with these guys,
drop a track with these guys
once a year, explore
rapping in Punjabi,
explore rapping in Hindi,
kind of making it all happen.
And I try to do it
more authentically
the way I would
probably do it here,
which is I speak half
English, half Punjabi when
I'm with my friends.
I would rap and
do the same thing.
And there's that movement.
There's the hip hop,
and just meeting
a couple of other artists
and how they're doing it.
So I'm actually working with a
company called Saavn as well,
which is owned by Jio,
which is the big telecom
company out there.
And they're putting cell
phones in everybody's hands.
So the movement is coming.
And I know they just
recently released a track.
Ranveer actually has
a track with Nas.
And it's fantastic
because what's
popular there is what was
popular here in the 90s.
So it's like that boom
bap, the hard core stuff.
They don't want you
to slow it down.
They want that Eminem.
They want that lyrical
miracle super fast stuff.
And out here,
you're being taught,
hey, no, you've got to
make it more melodic.
You've got to make it
simpler to understand it,
to make it more digestible.
So it's a breath of fresh air.
And I'm looking forward to
contributing to that culture
the best way I know how and
kind of moving it forward.
And Bollywood has always
had this reputation
of being a parody of
North American culture.
They'll have their cheesy
version of Spider-Man.
version of whatever.
This is an opportunity
for us not to have
a cheesy version of hip hop.
We can have an
authentic version of it.
And we can look--
especially for me, I believe we
should look to folks in France
because they found that.
And I feel like the UK
is doing the same thing.
UK, they had a lot of
rappers in the beginning.
Then once they found grime,
that became their own thing.
And I think that's
kind of what it is.
You have to sound
like your heroes
until you find your own voice.
And I think India
is having its time
to sound like
their heroes, but I
want us to find our own voice.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
KANWER SINGH: Yeah.
TY WARD: Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for coming over here.
My question is more
about philosophy.
of the Sikh.
To me, it was always
something to do with warriors
and the warrior's spirit.
And I was wondering
in your life overall,
how does it impact you?
How do you apply
daily through life's--
I don't know-- trials,
obstacles, and--
KANWER SINGH: I think
one of the symbols--
we have a double-edged sword.
And the double-edged sword
represents [INAUDIBLE]
which is spiritual
power and temporal power
or being involved politically.
So historically,
there were saints.
There were soldiers, and
everything in between.
And now kind of,
it's amalgamated
where you're supposed to be
the saint and the soldier.
But I think from a pragmatic
level, it makes a lot of sense.
You're not being encouraged to
isolate yourself from the world
and sit in your room and
meditate all the time,
and avoid challenges,
avoid temptation, and avoid
all these things.
You're encouraged to
be out in the world,
and be assertive and
view things accordingly.
So for me, I know
growing up, I probably
connected much more with Malcolm
X than with Martin Luther King.
I connected with
[INAUDIBLE] much more
than I did with Mahatma Gandhi.
Many people don't even know
that like Nelson Mandela,
there was a militant wing
for some of the things
that he did in the early on.
And I think for me, I
always kind of viewed
people-- that is a lot more
pragmatic in understanding
that sometimes, when fighting
oppression, you have to fight.
You can't simply sit in
or do a hunger strike.
You have to actually fight.
You have to speak up.
And now in modern
sense, for me, that just
means you can't be
passive aggressive.
You have to speak
in straight lines.
You have to be
clear with people.
Peace isn't always available,
and peace can always
be a priority.
And I love a quote
from Steve Jobs,
where he talked about the
rock tumbler and everyone
criticizing him for the
friction at his office.
And he's like, you put
rocks in a rock tumbler,
and the friction
polishes all the rocks.
And I noticed that with
myself, and I grew up
in a challenging
neighborhood in Toronto,
where we spoke a certain
way to each other.
And then once I got
a little bit older,
and started meeting people
from other neighborhoods,
and realizing that I was
considered crass or rude,
and not feeling
that I was myself.
I felt I was just a direct
communicator and feeling
that it's OK for there to
be a little bit of conflict.
It's OK for there to be
a little bit of friction
because from that,
a lot can grow.
We, as a species, are safer
now than we've ever been.
But we're more sensitive
to negative news
and negative violence.
And I think that we
might be doing ourselves
a disservice because of that.
And so for me and my
heritage, really promoting
being prepared all
the time, it really
means being able to
operate in any ecosystem.
And for me, that's always been
being the guy who stood out.
I can never be a fly on the
wall when I went certain places
or being in a country where 99%
of the people think I'm Muslim.
And 101% of the
time, I'm randomly
screened at the airport, and
really being mindful of this
and saying to myself, OK, well,
what are the things that I can
do, and saying, hey,
well, 20 years ago,
the average American, if they
thought beard and turban,
they thought Osama bin Laden.
What can I do now so when
the average person thinks
of beard and turban,
they think of Humble?
And when they think
of Humble, they just
think of funny, silly guy?
Like, fun-loving, great person
as opposed to he represe--
and I'm sure no other gentleman
with a beard and turban
would have an issue being seen
as a fun person, versus what
we had to deal with--
me growing up, going to New
York the first time in 2004,
and the type of challenges
that I went through with that.
But now, as an adult, I
see the value in that.
If I had children,
I probably wouldn't
want to shield them from that.
I think it built a
lot of character,
and it put me in a position.
And as well, I think the irony
of how the story has moved now
is there's so much.
I grew up in a world
where people are pushing
us to tolerate diversity.
And I think now we're
realizing that we
don't tolerate diversity.
We celebrate diversity.
Diversity, multiculturalism,
all of that, it's fantastic.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Well, you guys are dope.
This is LA, so you guys
are all fantastic out here.
But I think it's
just at a point now
where people are seeing
the benefits of it.
It is good for
every single person,
and we have so
much more in common
than we have differences.
And now it's a
challenge for even
me to speak to my community
and be like, all right,
you guys wanted to be
accepted because you chose
to wear turbans and beards.
You guys need to accept that
man for loving another man.
You need to accept that woman
for loving another woman.
You need to accept that
person over there who
decided they grew
up one way, but they
want to be something else.
And you don't get to have
an opinion on their choices,
especially since their
choices have no impact on you.
And it's just challenging
a belief that you have.
So I'm seeing this, and
I've experienced racism
at the hands of
homosexuals and kind
of being like, hey, we're
supposed to be on the same team
here.
We're oppressed
minorities in some sense.
But you realize
that human nature
has this kind of really--
divide and conquer
is a very efficient
way to control people.
So trying to be mindful of
that and finding the best ways
to fight those battles,
and I was actually
telling some friends back home.
I said, the Sikhs are
known for being warriors.
But we started losing
a lot more battles
when the battles became--
when the bullets
became information.
We don't have the necessary
mechanisms in place
when it's information warfare.
We don't have relationships
with the media
to change stories if
people are being attacked.
We don't have the necessary
relationship with sponsors
to be like, hey,
this publication
is spreading false information.
Can we lean on them with
your sponsorship dollars
to ensure that doesn't happen?
We don't have the most
effective lobbying groups.
So this is our next
level of warriorness,
because folks are still
thinking warriors is picking up
the sword.
And it's not.
The battles are internal,
and the new external battles
are not going to be fought
on the battlefield anymore.
They're going to be fought
behind the computer.
with political donations.
They're going be
fought that way.
And I think just
learning that art of war,
I think is important for
everybody in general.
And specifically,
that's something
that I'm trying to push upon
the people in my community.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thank you.
KANWER SINGH: We got to wrap up.
TY WARD: All right,
so I think we're kind
of out of time for questions.
But I'm curious do we have time
for one more special thing?
All right, so a picture is
worth a thousand words, right?
But I feel like spoken
word is priceless.
And we talked about
this beforehand.
I'd love to get you to give
us some spoken word right now.
KANWER SINGH: Definitely.
OK, so this one I wrote
in honor of my father.
It's called "Life
of an Immigrant."
And it was inspired
by his story.
So my father came to
Canada in the early 70s.
He had a master's
degree in economics,
but he immediately got to
work in a furniture factory
while he saved up to
get his taxi license.
And then he drove a taxi
probably from '75 to 2015
when he retired.
And he was always an
academic, but never got
to pursue academics.
And I always thought that
was super interesting.
And it did help me
develop a big chip
on my shoulder as to
what I needed to be
to prove his sacrifices right.
And that in itself became
a challenge for me.
But I did write a
piece in his honor.
It's called "Life
of an immigrant."
Told him the grass was
greener, what an endless flood
of possibilities.
Katrina, watch
him drown in debt.
Land confiscated by
the local government,
so he flies high in a
jet plane, plain clothed,
just expose them to the
harsh wonders of life.
And his wife won't know
about the sweat soaked
in the bank notes sent home.
Boy getting grown,
he starts to groan.
His stomach's rumbling.
Hungry for a better
life, now he's
stumbling over foreign
phonetics and those verb tenses.
They're laughing at his accent.
It's not an accident, though,
that his masters in economics
isn't honored.
Most economic forefather
to hop his ass in a cab
and never bother getting
out that car or his dreams.
Memorize the route
and collect the fare.
It isn't fair when they
say you don't belong here
with your long beard and
that towel around your head.
Hear what was said.
Soak in the heat.
Can you relate?
Life of an immigrant.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
TY WARD: I gotta say, man,
it's been a real, real fun
time talking to you.
KANWER SINGH: I had
a lot of fun, man.
I appreciate it.
TY WARD: I feel like we're
just homies up here, which
is like the best way
they say you learn.
KANWER SINGH: And I
appreciate everybody
here skipping Coachella
to come see me.
That's the story
I'm telling myself.
They all have free tickets.
And they're like, no.
And this is probably the
entire population of LA
that's not in Coachella.
So I appreciate every
single one of you.
TY WARD: Exactly.
If you noticed,
your Uber ride was
like lightning speed over here.
KANWER SINGH: Yeah, I got
here just like-- yeah,
normally, it's like 45 minutes,
and I got here in seven.
TY WARD: Yeah, exactly.
He probably got here
before you left.
Well, I really gotta say, man,
thank you for sparing the time
and coming through and
really talking to us.
I really hope that everybody
got a lot out of this.
As we noted, Humble's book
"Unlearn" is out right now.
If you did not get here early
enough to get your own copy,
you can definitely buy
a copy off of Amazon.
It's a great book.
I have not finished
reading it yet,
but the best part is,
every single day I can just
pop open to a new page.
And it's just like
exactly what I needed.
KANWER SINGH: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]